OK, so the next step is for us to
understand how Python knows about this thing called the turtle.
But before we do that, here's your task. I want
you to reproduce this entire code on your computer. And
oh, and by the way, you can customize this
turtle. You can change it's shape. You can also change
its color, and you can change the speed at which
it moves. Let me quickly save and show you the
output. Alright. So it seems like we've changed a few
things about the turtle. Its color, which is yellow now,
and shape and also its speed. Oh, by the way,
if you need more information about how to customize your turtle.
There are some helpful links in the instructor notes. After
you have created your own custom square I want you to
take a screenshot of your output and post that on
the forum. Make sure to check this box before you continue.